now the latest on current a virus today
there have been over 26,000 cases in the
u.s. more than 340 people are now dead
more than three hundred and eleven
thousand cases and thirteen thousand
deaths worldwide the State Department
has raised its global travel advisory to
a level four that is the agency's top
warning level it is recommending that US
citizens remain in place or return home
and then this weekend at least eight
states with guidelines to stay home
joining me right now is the Acting
Secretary of Homeland Security
Chad wolf secretary thanks very much for
being here it's good to be with you this
morning so let's get to the very latest
the u.s. closing its border with Mexico
closing the Canadian border effective
this weekend is the president
considering a full shutdown of the
country for a period of time sir not not
at this time the president again to the
vice president and the task force has
been very aggressive and very
forward-leaning and providing a number
of guidance a number of information to
the American public we have the 15 days
to slow the spread so there's a number
of measures that we're asking the
American public to take you will see
that there's been another pair of
Governors particularly in New York in
California that have taken the extra
step and imposed some additional strict
measures and we certainly agree with
those measures there's going to be
certain communities that have widespread
community transmission that need to take
more aggressive measures than perhaps
other communities so again we're working
with them we're working with the state
and local and the governor's to do that
we continue to encourage them to take
those aggressive measures so let's talk
about those aggressive measures because
I'm in New York and there is a statewide
stay at home order or guard line
beginning Sunday at 8 p.m. California is
on lockdown it feels like it is a
shutdown so I mean you're not going to
do that across the country but it's
effective enough to do it in large
states well again I think we're focusing
on those states and those localities
that again have widespread community
transmissions in New York California
Washington there's other parts of the
country that we're seeing cases spike
and so those govern
are obviously looking at those numbers
closely they're in touch with the CDC
they're in touch with HHS and the task
force we're sharing that information and
in those localities in those locations
will night like New York City they're
having to take some aggressive measures
to slow that spread there are other
parts of the country perhaps in the
Midwest and the south that are not
seeing those same numbers they don't
need to take those aggressive measures
at this time but again we continue to
evaluate this really on a day-by-day
week-by-week basis it's like when you
and I were talking on the phone this
weekend and you said look if we shut
down New York in California maybe you
don't have to shut down for example
Nebraska maybe that's a chip that you
use later on is that the thinking that's
exactly right what we want to do is we
want to take aggressive steps again in
those communities that we're seeing
large numbers and outbreaks so that we
don't have to take those measures
elsewhere if we don't need to that's
really the concept behind it but again I
would say that there are measures that
the entire American public can take
regardless of where you're at
it's the 15 days to slow the spread that
the Vice President came out the task
force came out with so there's a number
of recommendations that any American can
take anywhere they live those
individuals that are in again high
transmission areas like New York City
like parts of California the governor is
asking them to take additional measures
so that again that we can control the
spread and mitigate that tell me
secretary about the CDC changes what we
heard this weekend from the Centers of
Disease Control and why that's important
and when our audience to better
understand what was significant about
the CDC's new regulations this weekend
so on Friday the CDC gave an order to
the Department of Homeland Security that
said to suspend the entry of any
individuals coming into the country
without proper documentation and that's
important for a couple of different
reasons one without that documentation
we see individuals coming into the
country without proper identity
documents without travel documents
without medical history and so it's very
hard to make a public health
determination on those individuals they
were also very concerned the CDC was
also very concerned about when we take
those individuals into custody and we
put them in Border Patrol facilities and
our ice detention facilities what type
of public health concerns in
issues that that raises and so it raises
a number of those issues serious danger
to not only other aliens but certainly
the DHS workforce and the American
people at large and said the CDC said we
need to suspend that so that's what the
department has been doing over the last
24 hours and I would say that it's
working
we've seen almost a 50% drop in illegal
apprehensions those illegal individuals
coming across our borders and this is
important because it's not just air
borders that you're now focused on but
it's land borders right that's exactly
right so we put in measures from 30
different countries travel restrictions
the president did very aggressive very
forward-leaning
early on in this in this process back in
early february we have travel
restrictions from 30 different countries
those are individuals coming into our
airports but we also need to look at
land ports of entry and maritime ports
of entry and we are doing that so again
also announced on Friday is limiting
essential travel across our land ports
of entry both with Canada and Mexico so
now what we're asking is non-essential
travel individuals coming across the
border for tourism for recreational
services if you want to go to your local
favorite restaurant we're asking you not
to do that what we're trying to do is
we're trying not to close the border
we're trying to keep the border open and
so we're trying to put measures in place
so that we can keep that little bit
trade and travel continue to flow across
both Canada and in the Mexican borders
what we see every day it's about 1.7
billion dollars in trade and commerce
that flow across the u.s. Canadian
border and that's everyday about 1.5
billion for Mexico every single day we
want to make sure that we continue that
trade we want to keep the supply chains
open keep the economy running but we
need to pay take measures now to limit
that essential travel to limit the
introduction and spread of the virus
yeah which leads me to the issue of
rethinking the coronavirus strategy no
doubt you saw the op-ed in the journal
last week which is questioning this
strategy because it is putting our
economy to a standstill I'm gonna get to
that in a moment I've got to ask you
about domestic travel a lot of people
are wondering they see reports that the
president is considering shutting down
all domestic
for thirty days is that in the cards
well I would say that the task force we
continue to look at it there's no
immediate plans to put travel
restrictions on domestic travel we
continue to be concerned again about
those high transmission areas like New
York like parts of California and
Washington so we're going to continue to
look at that if we see that we need to
put some targeted travel restrictions in
place we will do that but I will say
there's no immediate plans as of right
now for any widespread travel
restrictions because if we look at the
timeline in terms of the timeline of
border closings I mean this has been
pretty consistent in terms of closing
activity so what is the threat here how
worried are you that we're gonna see a
shutdown of the US economy already most
people are expecting a recession some
people are talking about even worse than
that what's the thinking around all of
these shutdowns and its impact on a
twenty trillion dollar economy
well again the discussions that we have
in the taskforce certainly consider the
economy and what we're doing on that but
first and foremost we need to protect
the American people from the virus so
that's that's first and that's really
what we look at and so the travel
restrictions that the president put in
place go to just that noon we continue
to look at countries around the world
look at their the number of cases they
they have to see if additional travel
restrictions need to be put in place so
one is it a containment or mitigation
strategy making sure that we don't
continue to import the the virus into
the US and we try to protect the
American public here but then of course
there's there's already transmission
here in the US so what are the measures
that we're putting in place here
domestically and there's a variety of
measures Task Force announces measures
every single day to do that and so it's
it's a two-pronged strategy a two-prong
approach here and so the measures that
we're taking at the border from the
Department of Homeland Security's
perspective is making sure that we're
again letting that trade and commerce
flow we got to keep the economy moving
we realized that the easiest thing for
us to do is to shut down our borders
completely let no one in we realize we
can't do that the American economy will
will not survive that so we want to make
sure that we put yeah
with thoughtful restrictions in place to
keep that cargo to keep that trade
moving and I know you're walking this
balance really quick we only have a
couple of seconds here you wanted to
mention this disinformation campaign
which continues we know this is
disinformation campaign coming out of
China but when people see reports it may
very well be cyber fraud right
absolutely we've seen a number of
reports and I've personally gotten
contacted a number of times about text
messages or these screenshots going
around saying that I know someone at DHS
and and they say we're gonna have a
national lockdown or a national
quarantine now we'll just say that's
absolutely false it's not true and it is
part of a disinformation campaign and
what we know whether it's Russia or
whether it's other cyber actors they
like to sow discord on any controversial
issue so it doesn't just have to be
elections it can be any issue and we're
seeing that now with the corona virus
and so what I would say to the American
people is don't believe it don't pass it
along and get your information from
trusted sources such as your state
officials and your federal officials and
and you're gonna have enough data by
middle of April end of April to figure
out if this is working right you're
gonna have enough data to understand
whether or not the moves you've taken
have actually been successful well
certainly the the doctors on the task
force CDC HHS and the like are really
tracking that day-by-day what I will say
is some of the measures that we are
putting in place some of the aggressive
measures that we're putting in place we
need to put those in place now to see
results in three to four to five weeks
from now and so again they may be
uncomfortable measures that you see in
New York City that you see in California
and elsewhere but we're doing that in
conjunction with those governors so that
we can see results in that three four
and five week period out and so I think
I think we will see some numbers in
April sometime to know if the measures
that we're putting in place are working
secretary it's good to see this morning
thanks very much for updating us thank
you today